3 2 1 partez
à les années continue fonce
si tu finis dans les dix premières tu
rejoindras l'équipe cet automne
la coupe du monde les jeux olympiques tu
pourras faire ce que tu veux
[Musique]
douze ans c'est trop jeune mousse et en
allemand on n'aurait pas dû accepter
tu vas prendre de vraies vacances
si valeron
moi c'est un des bons jours
mais attention c'est un cadre en carbone
à coeur au carbone
[Musique]
tu as besoin de te reposer mais je dois
m'entraîner cas pas le choix on parle de
ta s'empilent salut je m'appelle
victimes madison samedi de venir au bike
park dégâts et aura pas besoin de faire
il suffit de thé confluence et que tu te
laisses aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était un peu trop propre le début on
va camper au sommet alors ça doit
grimper vous avez peur ou coup pas du
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai certains coéquipiers pour une
course des preuves à vélo je vais le
faire avec elle
si tu te fais mal titre a entraîné pour
rien tu as envie de retourner là-bas où
c'est seulement pour faire plaisir à son
père
n'a aucune chance de gagner contre tous
ces adultes le plus important c'est
d'être présent ses amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais
c'était de la folie